[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon tu es dans une forme toi aujourd'hui
à battre toujours extraordinaire c'est
bien très bien très bien
bonsoir à tous et à toutes bonsoir
bonsoir à tous et à toutes elle a
parfaitement
nous allons maintenant réalise avec vous
une expérience tétouan j'entends des
oiseaux c'est l'arrêt break et derrière
j'en entends aussi bidon bon allez quoi
puis au gentil une expérience
extraordinaire que tout quand qu'on nous
a préparés alors là je vous demande une
concentration absolue
nous allons faire quelque chose des
pâtres l'expérience l'expérience abus à
l'aide d'un citron oui c'est exact
tiens au fait oui on peut en avoir
besoin d'un autre je vais et en faire un
tout de suite aux trois pattes notre
voie la fiac
oui qu'est ce que tu fais très
exactement la fiat toyota une crise de
crysis 2 600 merci partager ce qu'il
faut là sait jamais on va vers un peu
servi alors suivez-moi très attentif
nous resterons ici poussant un petit peu
comme un chien voilà ce que nous allons
faire nous allons écrit un message
secret pousse-toi trickett ne regarde
pas ce que je fait enrager moitié de la
prime il en est d'accord mais tu ne dois
pas voir ce que je vais tracé car nous
allons faire un message secret comme un
véritable agent secret très important
fabrice 006 city veut en quelque sorte
suivez moi j'ai tracé avec un vulgaire
stylo un cercle dans ce papier oui et ça
ça n'a rien d'extraordinaire tint un
cercle vulgaire bon attention jeu repose
cette feuille sur la table comme ceci se
passe on établit et maintenant je vais à
l'aide d'un demi citron que vous voyez
ici
si trop ordinaire vulgum si tron hommes
je vais prendre mes titres ona je prends
une allumette que j'avais aussi la
vulgaire aussi vulgar us à l'humus puis
je trempe
dans le jus de citron je vous signale
qu'on peut le faire également avec un
oignon mais je déteste l'oignon c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs que je tenais pas
à porter je te remercie a trop pleuré la
dernière fois il s'agit ne supporte pas
maintenant comme on allume était bien
trempé bon ben c'est assez pointu pape a
écrit un livre non bon et faire un signe
ne copie pas non mais je le regarde pas
il faut vraiment que ça marche bien
c'est le torticolis
je fais un signe très simple pour qu'on
puisse le reconnaître tout à l'heure à
la caméra bah non c'est pas ça crée
c'est tout le monde le reconnaît
non ils ne vont pas le voir maintenant
c'est là qu'est l'astuce système que
vous pouvez utiliser en classe
enfin en vaudrait peut-être mieux parce
que les professions serait pas content
bon ça te fait rire ça c'était sage en
classe toi au moins tu as encore au oui
tu es sûr de sang j'ai toujours assis
sur la quatrième branche
ah oui en bas c'est la meilleure près du
chauffage voilà effectivement c'est la
muse ensoleillé bon alors ça y est c'est
fait je vais plus vite - oui mais moi je
ne peux pas le faire mieux que ça car
j'ai besoin de réfléchir il faut passer
plusieurs fois
vous voyez que apparemment un sur le
métier remettez votre ouvrage vient très
bien pour les citations week apparemment
on ne voit pas grand chose sauf comme
c'est un petit peu humide on distingue
parfaitement ce que je vais faire mais
en réalité sur du papier blanc lorsque
ça sèche là ça n'a pas passé tu casses
mon jeu mais n'ont pas de casse pattes
on jettera ses insignes toussaint pas en
vente à la bougie
maintenant aux finesses comment faire
apparaître cette trace que dans ce
cercle
ce que vous vous demandez tous accusent
moi s'il te plaît parce que leur nom
je ne roule pas parce que tu es
tellement maladroit bah oui et si je
pense plumage tu si keira gym en route
la mab alors achevée sans ignifuges et
moi tu vois franchement bien croyez-moi
ce n'est pas possible parce que ça me
donne des raids et non n'est pas encore
un allume j'allume on y voit plus rien
oui mais non plus d'ailleurs à leur
attention
j'allume par les corrales thuram 500
faire marcher une allumette des farines
à voir comment savait-il juillot qu'est
ce que ce serait grâce à lui je souffle
je prends la bougie j'allume la bourse
je redresse ma bougie
la schl à lui mais tu ne pourras pas
saisir le papier censées lui qui les met
dans un geste d'une souplesse
extraordinaire vous vous cassez le bec
dans les gares donc je prends mon papier
sur lequel le signe est toujours
invisible
je peux dire au revoir parce que si ça
flambe oui je vais dire au revoir
on va pas tenir 26 minutes
je fais chauffer voilà le message secret
ans et cuit c'est cuit on peut manger
lyon attend ces appareils bas j'en sais
rien une seconde
voilà voilà ahola vous allez voir c'est
extraordinaire ça y est c'est magnifique
c'est pour lui c'est magnifique enfin
fait pour le pays africains voilà mon
ordi je vais t'en fait mais là pour
diriger h foot
bon je ne vais faire que des maîtrises
en fait un combat maintenant on va les
voir bell bell
j'ai très bien fait brillant regardez
attentivement dans une saison il y avait
un gros but en est trop de flash
s'élance fait un gros plan
oui voyez apparaître nettement sais pas
mais ne croit pas et coûtant maginot je
n'en peux plus je veux dire une chose
on a eu tort de enfin j'ai eu tort
d'approcher la bougie parce que là ça
n'a pas donné un résultat qui sera bien
faut pas l'approcher autant tu vois la
tuilerie à la fin je vais essayer au riz
j'ai essayé je m'en f à la st bon je
m'en vais vadocz jardin taipei a battu
mu a bien fait
wen ont pas son jour prenons notre calme
qu'hier le point commun vous le
conseillez on est pas d'argent les
palais fabrice heyries devenir une cible
gillot avant d'entrer quand même je fais
ce que je veux un
alors c'est quand même pas un bon ici
chez moi ah oui j'avais bien travaillé
cette semaine
oui mais prépare un petit point comme un
sympathique il est très très très bien
vous êtes tous prêts jouez avec nous
vous savez ce que vous avez à faire
c'est l'essentiel vous devez trouver
quel est le point commun entre les trois
choses qu'ils vont incarner
c'est à dire tous cancan belles belles
et pousse monsieur regarde toujours cet
endroit là toujours si l'on joue comme
ça c'est dit lui ce jeu
alors aujourd'hui tout con quand tu es
quoi le clocher d'une église
le clocher d'une église rachèterait aux
traits fins surmonté d'une girouette
oui d'un coq ou d'un bras tonnerre alors
tu sais on aperçoit de très loin dans la
campagne et je peux même d'ailleurs
appartenir à une grande église à une
cathédrale pourquoi pas mais je peux
être la cathédrale de chef par exemple
l'altitude ne me fait pas peur oui pas
non plus mais je suis un crayon oui à
crayons en bois avec une mine un crayon
qu'on n'est pas obligé de tijd au je
suis bien que vous mmes utiliser de
moins en mois vous vous servez des
stylos à bille de feutre ou vous faites
vite âge sur les doigts c'est tout ce
que vous y gagner moi je suis le crayon
avec lequel on peut écrire très fins
autres gros et puis j'ai encore à notre
avantage avec moi si vous n'êtes pas
content de ce que vous avez fait on nous
met face et là coup de gomme g disparaît
et on en parle plus
et voilà et ben moi je et ben moi moi
moi je suis un chapeau oui mais
attention pas n'importe quel chapeau pas
une casquette ça ne va pas non pas un
virage et une trop grosse tête
quand vous voyez les caméras n'ont pas
pas un képi non plus ça me donne l'air
méchant donc je suis un chapeau de clown
savez dans les cirques ya toujours deux
clowns y en a un qui a toujours un
costume avec des paillettes et un petit
chapeau blanc de travers voyez ce que je
veux dire mais là moi je suis ce chapeau
là c'est dommage gens n'est pas un sous
la main sinon je montreuil comme ça me
va bien
oui ça me va très bien voilà tu m'as dit
tout cas encore je suis un clocher je
suis un rayon oui quitte batby avec une
très bonne mine d'ailleurs et toi tu
m'as dit je suis un chapeau de clown à
pau oui un choc pour de clown un crayon
un clocher tout de même il me semble que
la sphère s'éclaircit vous avez trouvé
vous voyez de quoi il s'agit tout ça
finalement est extrêmement pointus c'est
ben voilà c'est pas qu'ils aient
lapointe et oui moines du chapeau de
clown près du crayon de la mine bien sûr
et du clocher et toi tu étais pas mal
trouvé à à bravo félicite valérie ses
origines félicite c'était bien trouvé et
vous aviez trouvé chez vous également de
quoi il s'agissait
c'est l'essentiel bravo fabien abella et
bien leur toucan oui j'ai beauty je ne
vous dis pas pourquoi je vous laisse
deviner
elle bat maintenant c'est à moi enfin
c'est à nous à tu vas bien soin moi ça
va ça va forme formations en forme
alors cette semaine à ça va être
difficile c'est vrai roj
pour mes tableaux ça va être un mot très
difficile l'attend crayon bah oui bon
alors comme d'habitude tu vas au tableau
oui j
si tu veux bien j'y vais mais dire une
chose oui je fatigue un peu
ah oui 4 ory tout à l'heure oui j'ai
tellement ri puis alors me lever comme
ça tout le bas oui oui c'est difficile
alors qu'est-ce que tu m'a préparé va
lasser c'est terrible a fait un mot en
douze lettres 12 ton tableau va être
assez grand oui mais il va falloir que
j'écrive relativement petit alors douze
lettres qui commence pas par un c'est un
c mais voilà ainsi mais alors tu fais 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10
et puis le 11e alors c'est un e voilà
alors écoute comme c'est difficile je
vais quand même te donner tout de suite
la lettre du milieu c'est à dire mettons
là la 5e un tout ça il aime l'être en
bas oui parce que tu sais c'est
difficile
alors alors je te la donne tout de suite
oui et après je te laisse deviner que tu
veux alors la cinquième lettre c'est un
rrr voilà alors maintenant à toi
j'attendais question des feux de ne pas
être trompés dans leurs taux graff non
voyons que tu me dises à chaque fois
puis finalement c'est un désastre
alors on commence rapidement pour les
choses classiques c'est un animal up
non non allez y c'est cesser ces deux
c'est une fleur non non c'est pas une
fan art moi j'ai pas un arbre m'est
passé par brana qu'est-ce que ça peut
bien être que cette affaire c'était à un
homme non non non non non non est-ce que
ça se mange
oh non non est-ce que d'abord ce qu'il
ya dans la forêt oh oui oui ils ont
beaucoup il en faut il en fait
indispensable oui sinon on ne vivrait
pas vivre est pas dans l'antre c'est pas
une l'autre mais s'il n'y avait pas ces
choses les plantes ne pourrais pas vivre
assez avec passage semaine lâche n'y
aurait pas de plantes à l'enrôlement
gentil avec toi mais qu'est ce que c'est
cette c c'est un d'une partie d'une
plante non non non
non c'était une partie de plans non je
ressens par un ctp sais pas ce que c'est
on sentirait les citadins par exemple
ils s'en vont le dimanche à la campagne
pour respirer pour rigoler pirelli
oui enfin c'est un décorum l'ailé les
hommes en met un peu partout dans le
chewing gum non pas dans le dentifrice
ils ont inventé des tas de choses à aa
tu vois que je suis j'en tire une
substance c'est une substance contenue
dans les plans là j'avais demandé à tous
quand si c'est une substance voilà il ya
trouvé alors là je crois je crois que
j'ai trouvé effectivement ne ferait ce
point pouces moussu de la chlorophylle
exactement la refile mais j'ai
l'impression que cette fois ci tu ne
t'es pas trompé d'orthographe dis donc
je me suis pas trompé mais c'est
extraordinaire
veux-tu mesplé entièrement le mot
chlorophylle à charles bien alors alors
c'est oui h hll aux rousses
we r r est là haut encore 1 op alors phh
y y
2 l guy novès et le e a effectivement
mais tu as fait des progrès
extraordinaires voilà difficile tu as
parfaitement bien orthographier lâcher
bientôt pouces ou suis je vais venir
t'embrasse et c'est très bien ça va ça
s'appelait encore ils bravent à détruire
peut faire un baiser parce que vraiment
à bord et à fourmies voilà bien alors
épatant là je suis assez fier de moi
parce qu'à 6 et widgets et c'était quand
même - oui c'était quand même difficile
appelant refusera très difficilement des
comptes
on arrive à regret qu'il a fait aux
marques fabrice à ça ça s'explique oui
parce que la chlorophylle
c'est très important pour moi et c'est à
elle que je bats ma ma belle couleur
verte
comme les feuilles de tout là d'un forêt
et tous les arbres de la forêt
d'ailleurs c'est elle aussi qui me
permet de respirer de profiter de l'air
du soleil
c'est pour ça qu'un si par exemple
j'étais une feuille de salade
j'aimerais mieux est une feuille du
dessus bien
werth qu'une feuille du milieu date ou
toute blanche qu'est ce que tu en penses
apparemment c'est une question de swarm
à ça qu'on le choisit les feuilles comme
on veut irene enfin effectivement toi tu
est ouvert et c'est grâce à l'accord
grâce à la chlorophylle
bravo pouces mais aussi je suis content
de l'avoir fait tout horton ont fait ses
gammes en petit poucet mais régresse
merci et encore merci
tetra de quoi encore oui qu'est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas que tu es un peu le maître de
cérémonie un oui je prendrais s'occuper
de la suite d'une opération illicite est
mon petit ami
je comprends très bien enfin nous avons
autre chose à faire maintenant eh bien
nous retrouvons à leur bébé à elle va
chanter et bien sûr un jour elle chante
toujours écouté avec attention
non c'est pas moi c'est moins loin que
consul calais oui mais malgré qu'une
marche et droit devant soi parler d'une
course à pied quand on y est c'est pas
moi c'est moi loin
[Musique]
y aller oui mais laïcité
c'est la raison pour laquelle je n'ai
pas hésité un instant lorsque mon ami le
commandant petit pont m'a demandé de
l'accompagner dans un voyage d'étude au
pôle nord nous avons longuement séjourné
à la base de recherche scientifique
qu'il a établi sur une banquise
je ne sais plus d'ailleurs très bien
laquelle enfin bruxelles a pas là oui tu
as dû revoir déjà du temps vu que je me
suis décidé à écrire un livre de
souvenirs
regardez voilà le manuscrit impression
paul est rare pourrait peut-être nous
lire quelque part oui oui oui
ah oui bon d'accord c'est à dire voyons
je choisirais le morceau le plus
représentatif de mon style
concentrez-vous oui ça y est le voici
il est là devant moi c'est le pôle nord
gelée 10ème très nettement quel choc et
l'émotion
je dois tout de suite fournir un
électeur une précision scientifique de
la plus haute importance
comme son nom l'indiqué le pôle nord
n'est pas située au sud est a bien fait
pour qu'ils écoutent oui j'écoute je
crois que oui
le commandant est un galant tome il me
tend la main et mad a posé le pied sur
la banquise
oh mon dieu celle ci a tendance à fondre
car nous sommes en plein coeur de l'été
les habitants de cette région déshéritée
fait aujourd'hui le retour de leurs
bienfaiteurs qui rend petit pour mon ami
il organise à notre honneur
une fête je ne l'oublierai jamais des
femmes vêtues de kimonos m'apporte de
gros bouquet de fleur d'oranger et me
font goûter au couscous traditionnel
soudain soudas la tempête c'est l'aide
inattendue soudaine brutale la casquette
du commandeur ça va ça
l'émission d'appels que maître de moi
s'accroche à ma jupe
ainsi commence la première journée au
pôle nord au pôle nord au pôle nord oui
oui les à léopold la wii très bien tu es
le seul que ce récit véridique ne fasse
pas pleurer au cégep en 2010 à cause de
ton inculture mais je te préviens tout
de suite quand mon livre paraîtra je ne
te le débit cas serait pas gentil ça
quand même belle bella à mon ami au
revoir bel bel et bon voyage au pôle
nord
bonjour à la zambie quand on voir belbel
il ne te sera pas dédicacé au volant et
peut-être que nous par la même occasion
leur a pas laissé aller tellement
contente de vous montrer ce livre se
livre sur le pôle nord ou à mon avis
elle n'a jamais mis les pieds
ras enfin me dis pas pouces moussu que
rien de ta frappé bas si je suis d'abord
quoi bein des tas de choses
oui des tas de choses et plein de choses
mais tu sais pas quoi bah pas
précisément tu sais je dormais un peu
aller ça revient est assoupi gentiment
parle
et toi tu ou encore moi j'ai trouvé tout
parfait ça m'a beaucoup impressionné par
le passage télé minarets qui s'écoule
des minarets au pôle nord c'est une
chose tout à fait classique avec des
femmes en kimono au pôle nord c'est
encore classique haristoy pas que le
team no ça peut se trouver au japon non
attends pôle nord les minarets en
afrique du nord non au pôle nord ou dans
tout le monde musulman les minarets le
couscous le couscous oui l'afrique du
nord
plus qu'aux pôles d'or et puis encore
quelques bêtises comme ça que je vois
c'est non mais ça continue ça continue
elle l a beaucoup d'imagination à nos
pôles langues jamais mis les pieds et
nous reprenions notre expérience de tout
à l'heure à ouïr ya ce travail trop je
passe la bougie par lille à lyon 6 voilà
je vais essayer de pas le noircir comme
tout à l'heure
et tu vois que le citron apparaît très
bien d'ailleurs
alors là cette fois ci c'est
extraordinaire
regarde prévoir regarde moi ça c'est
vraiment sa base un petit peu mais quand
même assez bien alors à cette fois ça y
est alors tu vois cette belle couleur
orange et bien c'était étonnant non
alors alors je vous propose de fabrice
exactement la même chose que nous avons
gagné nous avons gagné fait la même
chose chez vous peut-être pas du premier
coup mais après ça ira tout seul bonsoir
à tous et à toutes merci de votre
attention et merci mon cher maître pour
cette idée absolument géniale
bravant tous contre pierre fabre est
bien pire si bonsoir à tous
[Musique]
m
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]